Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie
We just found out about a really cool
Ahsoka
Episode five deleted scene
from the Anakin
Skywalker parts of the episode,
so we'll break it all down.
I saw people expecting them
to put this on the Blu ray
when they release that next year,
but I don't think they're going to do that
just because they've been releasing
the physical media
for The Mandalorian
to their Star Wars series.
And we haven't seen
a lot of deleted scenes on those yet.
if you're brand new to the channel, I'm
doing videos for all the Ahsoka episodes.
Be sure to subscribe to get them.
We're also doing a giveaway for Disney
Plus memberships.
All you had to do to enter
that is just be a subscriber
and post all your favorite moments
from Anik and Skywalker on the video.
But there is a ton of stuff
that gets cut from all the live action
Star Wars series like The Mandalorian.
So it's no surprise they shot a lot more
Anik and Skywalker scenes for the episode
that got cut at the last minute.
this deleted scene, would have happened
towards the end of their flashback
fight scenes
when they were on Mandalore
during the events of the Clone Wars Season
seven, that final siege of Mandalore
in A can tell Ahsoka
he doesn't remember the battle
because he wasn't there
during the actual event
because it was happening at the same time
and can Obi-Wan
Kenobi were rescuing Emperor Palpatine
at the beginning of Revenge of the Sith
the end of the Clone Wars Season
seven episodes were meant to overlap
with Revenge of the Sith
and show you what happened during order 66
during all those events
from Ahsoka in the Clones perspective
like Rex, that was one of the reasons
why they had the Rex flashback
cameo scene too,
because he was there
when that was happening and he was a big
part of the circus experience
during Order 66 in their flashback,
after young Ahsoka gets frustrated again
about the events of Order 66 and and again
turning into Darth Vader,
he says she's learned
nothing like, Oh, you're still mad about
that whole Darth Vader thing.
She's focusing only on the Darth
Vader of it all.
It hasn't been able to get
past that all these years.
and again.
Starts fighting her again,
giving her the life or death choice.
Only this time he's fighting her
with his original lightsaber hilt.
But the kyber crystal
has started to bleed red.
So it's Darth Vader versus Ahsoka.
A bit of a callback to their fight
during Star Wars Rebels, during the fight,
his eyes turn sith yellow.
He's meant to look more like he did during
that final battle in Revenge of the Sith
on Mustafar with Obi-Wan Kenobi
and in the original version,
the scenes we saw in Episode five,
he just kicks
the older Ahsoka back into the world
between Rose
and they continue their fight.
here's
where the bigger deleted scene starts.
What he did in the original version
of the deleted scene
is that he kicks the younger soldier
from Mandalore into the future
on Mustafar,
which happened shortly after Order 66.
just charting Asuka's
timeline in the Clone Wars finale.
It would have happened
right after her ship crashed
and she visited the Clone Troopers graves,
leaving her last remaining lightsaber
behind to trick the Emperor
into thinking that she died
and then went into hiding
in the outer rim.
be Ahsoka Episode five deleted
scene was meant to be a what if scenario
like type of alternate reality scene.
What if Ahsoka came to Mustafar
when he was fighting Obi-Wan Kenobi
instead of running into the outer
rim to hide and leaving her last light
saber behind?
so was Ariana Greenblatt's younger Ahsoka
because in a can find on
Mustafar happened
shortly after the final siege.
The Mandalorian was still
the younger version of her character.
Manikin versus the Sokka fight
just continues on mustafar in the lava
flows there with Aniket looking exactly
like he did during Revenge of the Sith.
Having gone for that, Emperor Palpatine
had already named him Darth Vader,
but he didn't have the armor yet.
Like he had been scarred by Obi-Wan
Kenobi.
some of the things
this Ahsoka Mustafar scene was also meant
to pay off was and again,
having the red lightsaber on Mustafar.
That's
why they had that during the episode.
the whole idea
is that originally when George Lucas
was making Revenge of the Sith, he wanted
an akin to be fighting Obi-Wan Kenobi
with his red light saber on Mustafar
There were a bunch of deleted scenes
that were just released about this.
Like we're just learning about this
in present day
years After Revenge of the Sith came out,
there
had originally been a much longer Revenge
of the Sith deleted scene
showing how Anakin Skywalker,
now Darth Vader, got his red lightsaber
right after the
scene where he kills Mace
Windu in Palpatine names him Darth Vader.
The Sith Palpatine was going
to take an Akin to one of his Sith
lairs deep underneath course in the lower
sub levels.
we briefly visited
the lower levels during and or,
but the ancient parts of the city
extend even lower than that.
Like it goes way way further That's where
Palpatine Sith Temple would have been.
most people who learned about this
believed that
the Sith Temple was meant to be deep below
the Jedi Temple,
and it was meant to be part of the reason
why Palpatine was able
to use the dark side of the force
to cloud the Jedi Council's vision.
So much basically stopping them
from sensing the fact that Palpatine
was a Sith Lord standing in front of them
for all these years,
like right in front of your faces.
Why didn't you notice him?
Because he was using
the dark side of the force.
definitely would have made more sense
if he had constructed a temple
deep, deep below the Jedi temple
and just kept it active.
24 seven
and that's why Yoda didn't sense Emperor
Palpatine until the very last minute.
Normally you would expect somebody
on the Jedi Council to be like,
Wait a minute, isn't there like a
Sith Lord
just like standing out there
right in the open?
Shouldn't we do something about that?
And just completely preventing his rise
from ever happening in the first place?
and in this Revenge of the Sith
deleted scene,
Palpatine takes an action
now Darth Vader to his Sith temple,
and in one of the chambers,
he has a red Kyber crystal.
Palpatine orders the newly minted
Darth Vader to use the red crystal
to create a new lightsaber and use it
to humiliate and destroy the Jedi.
and again Places the red Kyber crystal
in his new Darth Vader lightsaber ignites
the blade in the red glow illuminates
his eyes, which turn a menacing
sith yellow Now, remember, in the
theatrical cut of Revenge of the Sith,
his eyes were already yellow
when he first went to move too far
to kill the Emperor's
collaborators inside the separatist fleet.
part of
the deleted scene where he constructs
his new red light saber were meant to show
how his eyes turned sith yellow.
This also explained
why in the deleted scenes that we got
from Revenge of the Sith, that Anakin
Skywalker fought Obi-Wan Kenobi
with a red light saber on Mustafar
not blue like that theatrical cut.
some of the Darth Vader comics
that Marvel published a little while ago
also dealt with him constructing his red
light saber in a slightly different ways.
They kind of changed things
after the fact that this deleted scene
that George Lucas originally envisioned.
but in the new Ahsoka Episode
five deleted scene of an accident Ahsoka's
fight on Mustafar
Dave Filoni was going to pay off
this older
deleted scene
that we had been robbed of in
I believe in the new version of the scene
that Ahsoka was seeing,
Anakin had defeated Obi-Wan Kenobi,
so would also been like a
what if situation.
What if an Incan one on Mustafar
instead of losing to Obi-Wan Kenobi?
Then during this new version of the Ahsoka
versus and again fight,
he kicks her back into the world
between worlds.
So there was like a whole lot of stuff
going on in this deleted scene.
And one of the reasons why I think
Dave Filoni cut it from the episode
is that it made things way more confusing
just in general.
but in the final version
that we just watched on Disney plus Dave
Filoni just cut
and so it looks like anyone is kicking her
from Mandalore
back to the world between worlds.
there were so many people after episode
five who were just confused in general
about what an intense lesson to Ahsoka
was supposed to be like.
What was the point
of all their flashbacks?
What was he trying to teach her?
Their fight on Mustafar would have made it
just way, way more confusing.
would have been super cool to see, though
Dave Filoni also probably cut it
for budgetary reasons.
The reason most of the star Wars
live action episodes, Mandalorian and
everything from all the shows are so short
and runtime is mostly a budget thing
because there's so many special effects,
visual effects just driving their costs
up like millions and millions of dollars.
Just add a couple of extra
seconds of screen time.
That's
why you always hear people complaining.
Why are these Marvel episodes so short?
Why are these Star Wars episodes so short?
It's all because of budget
for the most part.
they probably filmed the Mustafar scene,
then cut it before they spent a couple
more million dollars of post-production
visual effects, polishing it
like it got cut during that previous stage
before it went to special effects.
it also seems like that's when the Revenge
of the Sith deleted scene of him
building his red light saber
in the alternate Mustafar fight got cut.
That's why it looks like PS2 graphics
that we're actually seeing in present day.
Marvel does this kind of thing
all the time.
They'll delete scenes like this
before they get polished
in post-production,
like Banner turning into Professor Hulk
during Avengers Infinity War.
That's why it looks so janky
because they basically cut it
early in the process this by like an extra
15 minutes of Ant-Man Skywalker
that they just messed around with
and then cut at the last minute.
let me know in the comments.
If you would have rather Dave Flow
and he kept that deleted scene
in the Ahsoka episode,
it would have made the episode
a few minutes longer,
but I don't think that
they're going to release it online
just because I don't think they finished
the episode in post-production.
But I also don't think
this is the last time
we've seen Alnwick and Skywalker return.
I think we'll get at least
one more Anakin Skywalker cameo seen
before the finale.
But early theory right now
it'll be force goes and again
Skywalker
cameos seemed like the end of Obi-Wan
Kenobi with quite gone gen showing up
like it'll be force goes in
and can Skywalker coming to give Ahsoka
another pep talk helping
drive her into the events
of the Thrawn movie
because we know he's
coming back to the galaxy
So The New Republic, the Ahsoka
characters are going to take a huge L
at the end of the season, no matter what.
The other big reminder too,
is that The Mandalorian Season four
is meant to take place
right after Ahsoka season one,
and that'll be like the last thing
that happens before the Thrawn movie.
So part of the end of a circle
will push into the beginning
of Mandalorian Season four.
that's
why we saw all the scenes of the Shadow
Council
during the Mandalorian Season three.
That's like the crossover plot
with what's happening on Ahsoka right now.
By the end of the
Mandalorian Season four, his war against
the New Republic should have started.
And it was like
pick up at the beginning
of the Thrawn movie, kind of like they did
the beginning of Revenge of the Sith
in the middle of a giant battle.
read for watching Ahsoka
Episode
5 with all these Anakin flashbacks?
Do you kind of want Dave Filoni
to do a live action Clone Wars movie?
Like they kind of skip
from Attack of the Clones
where the Clone Wars
began right after that, too?
Revenge of the Sith. Like
they completely skipped the Clone Wars
and then covered it on the TV show.
Shouldn't we do a live action
version of the actual Clone Wars?
I know.
There are a lot of questions about what
the other main
characters are doing right now.
While the stuff on Facebook is happening,
they'll be answered
mostly during the Mandalorian season four.
Like what is Grogu doing right now?
What's Mando the rest of the Mandalorians
doing right now?
Shouldn't they be helping
Ahsoka is Luke Skywalker doing right now?
Some of that they might leave to answer
for the Thrawn movies,
but expect more answers about all this
during the Mandalorian season four.
That probably will not release
till the very end of next year
or early 2025, depending on when
all the strike stuff gets figured out.
for those of you
asking about a serious season two,
they did start work on that
like early work right before the strike.
But I don't think the scripts
have been written,
so that probably wouldn't
release till like after the Thrawn movie,
or at least after the Mandalorian season
four at some time.
But the big report right now
is that they've already soft
renewed Ahsoka for season two.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss any of that.
My full Ahsoka Episode
6 video we'll post next week.
After they release it, we'll get way
more of Thrawn, more Ezra Bridger
since most of the rest of the
Ahsoka episodes will be concerned with
what's happening in that other galaxy.
click here for that video.
Update the link as soon as I post it
and click here for all my episodes.
Thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe.
And this is the way!